and action
it's a boat full of underdogs
representing an underdog nation in three
two one row rowing particularly in the
1920s was one of the most attended
Sports from the United States the boys
in the boat is about strong tough kids
but they were poor and hungry they're
rowing because it was the only way they
could stay in college well what's that
about making some money yeah the rolling
team Iran you get a part-time job
included cheap place to live all you
gotta do is make the team the stakes
were much higher for them eight-man
crew's most difficult team sport in the
world most of you will not be chosen and
they gave him an edge but Washington
boat has taken the lead Washington has
done it these guys at the University of
Washington taking on the seniors I got
nine seconds under the course record
then taking on the fraternity kids and
then taking on the Nazis
every film we've ever seen that has an
underdog in it you're always rooting for
that you can pull yourself up from
nothing and succeed
there's lots of times when the human
Spirit prevails over circumstances that
it doesn't seem that they ought to be
able to Prevail over George understood
what the heart of the story was it
reminds us of what we're capable of when
we pull together
the actual story of what they went
through it was really spectacular for
all the people who didn't believe in you
one as